Donald Trump took part in a bizarre public
statement.
The dog that took part in the raid that led
to the death of ISIS leader, Abu Bocker al-Baghdadi
and every aspect of this public statement,
or I guess we would call it sort of like a
conference of sorts, was very, very odd.
Now, number one, as if we needed more proof
that Donald Trump just doesn't understand
dogs in the video I'm going to play for you.
Look at how Trump is just so far from the
dog, clearly has no interest in it.
It's really a prop like most of the things
and people around Donald Trump.
It's a prop for his own purposes, but it's
even more noticeable with the dog where normal
people, you know, who don't have like a fear
of dogs so to speak.
Um, they react to dogs in a way that seems
human, I guess is the best way that I would
put it.
And you'll see here that Donald Trump calls
the dog brilliant and smart based on him,
I guess spending time with the dog, but he
just can't seem to relate to the dog in a
way that seems normal.
Take a look.
al-Baghdadi is gone.
But that was a flawless attack and I just
picked quite a few of them and we just gave
Colin a medal and a plaque and it's really
a, and I actually think Kona knew exactly
what was going on, but a dog that is very,
very special, and we could maybe say something
about the type of dog and you're going to
put a muzzle on the dog.
And I thought that was a good idea, but then
it gets even more violent, John.
So I had a choice, but then now the dog is
incredible, actually incredible.
We spent some good time with it and so brilliant.
So smart.
Yeah, just the genius.
Brilliant dog.
Trump can obviously tell is this seeming strange
to anybody else?
It went on with Trump calling the dog, the
ultimate fighter and the ultimate everything
in terms of sniffing drugs.
I guess Trump means sniffing out drugs or
something like that.
But also I didn't think that this dog did
that.
This was a dog that is a military dog.
Take a look at this.
Special dogs, they're very hard to get.
This particular dog is, this is the ultimate
fighter.
Ultimate everything ultimate in terms of a
sniffing drugs.
We have, uh, we spent a tremendous amount
of money on drug equipment that the boater,
Nan, I was talking to the people, I say, well
is there anything better than this equipment?
No sir.
The only thing better is a dog, a dog.
This type of dog.
Exactly.
Cause it's a certain type of dog,
right?
It's a certain type of dog that Trump can't
identify and knows nothing about, but it's
definitely a certain type of dog.
Uh, one more clip from this very strange moment
and it's pretty amazing, but they are really
better.
We had a case where we had drugs at a, the
cylinder of a car and it was undetectable
by this very expensive machinery, which is
really amazing machinery.
But still it was undetectable.
The dog came in, wa jumped in the hood pointing,
you know, open the hood and knew exactly.
It's incredible.
The sense of smell or whatever it may be.
Preferably sense of smell.
So they're incredible animals and thank you
all very much.
Yeah, it was, it's sense of smell or something.
Who knows.
Anyway, right.
Does this dog have anything to do with sniffing
drugs at the border?
As far as I know, this is a military dog that
has nothing to do with that whatsoever.
It's like Trump just can't make stuff up and
tell the truth that can't, he can't not make
stuff up.
He can't simply tell the truth.
They had to, by the way, put Mike Pence in
the photo op touching the dog because it's
very clear.
Trump doesn't go anywhere near dogs.
He has no empathy for another living being
he, he even maybe appears to be afraid of
the dog actually from, from what I saw, not
even going near it.
I don't know anything about that.
The dog seems to actually be able to sniff
out sociopath's and it is signaling big time
around Donald Trump.
Seriously though, both Trump and Melania avoided
any contact with the dog during this entire
public appearance and check out how awkward
it is before this.
When Trump and Melania come out and announced
that they have cone Nan the dog there
morning.
So this is Conan right now, probably the world's
most famous talk.
I don't think I have to use the word probably.
And Colin is a incredible, it's an incredible
story.
I learned a lot about this particular type
of dog.
Could Trump and Melania look any more uncomfortable
and have any more space between them and the
doc, this reminded me of when in June I went
to LA and was on the Joe Rogan program.
After the show I took a picture with Joe and
a bunch of people, the pictures on my Instagram
if you want to see it.
A bunch of people reached out to me and they
say, David, why are you guys, uh, standing
so far apart?
And when I looked at the picture, there are
like maybe six inches between Joe and I. Melania
and Trump seemed to be like 10 feet from this
dog that they claim to think is just so great
and wonderful and lovely in every way.
They just can't even be around a dog in a
normal way.
And it might be lack of empathy that prevents
Trump from being around dogs.
It also could be his known germaphobia, who
knows?
But a very strange moment.
And I think that this is what people around
Trump imagine helps to humanize him because
he clearly doesn't relate to people in what
we would call a normal way.
I think a pretty big failure, but because
very obviously not relating to the dog in
a normal way either